[Music]
what if the Clippers took a leap of
faith and the front office made a
decision that would change the entire
feature of a franchise the Los Angeles
Clippers select Stephon curry
stepping Gori the best shooter in the
draft rules number one it's a great job
by the Clippers this is a special player
going to us a great situation every
night you're gonna be playing against
the best in the world you can be friends
off the court but once you get on the
court it's all about me our business
what if business were handled Clippers
won stoppable what a heck of a race
little coppers I know that but
Clippers franchise is reborn the rise to
stardom was inevitable
announcing he will star in a Space Jam
Steph Curry has blossomed into a
superstar Steph Curry is changing the
game as we know there is the best
shooter on the planet what if he broke
the game shooting from deep and his four
point line listen there's gonna be some
changes out west
what if landscapes change and the King
does not return home
I felt like this is the next step in my
journey you look at the prod James in
the West I mean there's not an easy game
in the Western Conference what in Los
Angeles was the true battleground
the curry was David and James was
Goliath versus Lakers Chris Paul
[Applause]
hurry us to back
against LeBron James berry the drive
reverse landlocked by James James comes
right back what if the King cannot be to
throne what if he knew how the future
would unfold would your decision be the
same with the first pick in the 2009 NBA
Draft the Los Angeles Clippers select
who do you think's been drafted oh not
not about the Clippers